so you're in the new live-action  Cinderella which I am so excited to see  and you play a version of the fairy  godmother will you tell us more about  that yeah you know they called and they  asked me to play the fairy godmother  as I call him/her babe them she it  whatever and you know all I could think  was that you're asking me to play  Whitney Houston part I love that you  know that what I love about the position  is that it really speaks to my brand for  lack of a better word which is about  challenging gendered norms and  stereotypes what does it mean to be a  man  what is masculinity exactly and why do  we in this culture since that masculine  is better than feminine I say when I was  trying to live up to the expectations of  others  hmm I was broke and bankrupt and jobless  when I chose myself here we are yeah I  agree  subscribe to my channel subscribe to my  channel subscribe to my channel  subscribe my channel please don't make  me keep going